la polémique benjamin ludwig n'en finit
pas d'enfler depuis que le jeune homme a
posté une vidéo de lui en train de
croquer dans une église le milieu
catholique s'insurge juste ton père qui
devrait mettre une tarte à te dire
arrête de dandiner va travailler alors
que benjamin et menacés quotidiennement
des jeunes se sont introduits dans le
domicile de ses parents récemment ya
plusieurs fois des gens qui sont venus
cagoulé armé chez mes parents et les
provocations répétées de benjamins n'ont
rien arrangé les choses provoquant la
mobilisation de nombreux croyants à
leurs prières et rassemblements de
catholiques dans la rue pour protester
contre benjamin ludwig les images vous
choque-t-elle
alors à ce que les messages ou choc on à
mathieu boyer avec nous responsable
civitas paris catholique militant merci
d'être là si nadine amrani étudiant en
droit et journaliste média livre bonjour
si également d'être là merci à floriane
bouger étudiante en êtes vous êtes une
amie très proche de 2000 à merci d'être
là également et alors c'est vrai que on
va revoir un petit peu cette prière dans
la rue qui est votre initiative tout à
fait vous vous êtes contre cette
initiative ah oui où nous nous sommes
mobilisés déjà pour préparer ce bluff n
ce blasphème cet outrage que nous a fait
benjamin nous ne sommes pas dans un
incident d'un message de violence mais
de paix nous sommes là pour réparer et
prier pour cette personne qui est venue
outragé les catholiques alors on va voir
et une centaine de personnes qui ont
répondu présent regarder
[Musique]
m
non
alors vous il y en a beaucoup qui sont
pas d'accord avec ce rassemblement vous
jours à venir
c'est moi qui chante elle vous dit non
c'est la wii c'est benjamin qui choqués
vous venez pas choqué non de la même
manière que j'étais pas choqué par le
toit de benjamin même si je trouve que
c'est un abruti et qu'il a laissé un
petit merdeux qui aurait pas dû faire ça
moi je suis pas là je vous avez le droit
de manifester votre foi comme comme vous
avez envie après moi je trouve qu'on est
quand même dans un retour en arrière je
me sens quand il revient cent ans en
arrière c'est à dire que le blasphème on
n'a plus droit à la provocation envers
les religions on n'a plus droit alors
bientôt on pourra plus embrasser dans
des films ce sera comme dans cinéma
paradiso ce sera censurée par l'église
on fera diminuer mais il faudra cacher
les baisers voilà moi je trouve qu'il ya
une dérive aujourd'hui très dangereuse
de société vous voulez je crois à
rechristianiser la france moi j'aurai la
relaxe 6 est encore plus parce que je
trouve que c'est très dangereux alors
zinedine qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ça ben moi je trouve que l'erreur
allaient plutôt dans le raisonnement de
géraldine si je peux me permettre c'est
que les catholiques ce qu'ils demandent
c'est tout simplement le droit d'être
respectés ils ont pas vocation à
s'étendre à prendre le pouvoir y'a pas
louis saez qui va revenir comme ça enfin
je vraiment je n'arrive pas à comprendre
moi en tant que citoyen français et
surtout aussi en tant que croyant il me
semblait important d'apporter tout mon
soutien à la communauté catholique d'
apporter tout mon soutien à tous ces
gens qui étaient là étaient d'ailleurs
vers s'annonce calme en prie ne mettre
pas mal de ballons personnes oui 10
millions oui pas de poids des millions
et pourtant ils ont quand même subi
encore une fois un nouveau perturbé mans
parce que une perte nouvelle
perturbation pardonnez moi même en fait
ils ont su mais non même pas on a droit
français excusez moi mais vous accepter
qu'une personne passe dans les rangs des
gens qui sont en train de prier et les
insultes de fachos mme
banon mais après c'est à la fin du
rassemblement m après j'imagine pas ce
que vous avez peut-être aussi des
positions si vite à 9 et 15 mai où on a
vraiment pris et donc voilà votre
discours mais votre positionnement par
ailleurs gilbert des messieurs
brouillent et moi j'ai une question pour
vous et elle vous concerne
personnellement
vous êtes l'organisateur de ce
rassemblement moi je ne suis pas choqué
par les images mais c'est vous que je
vais interroger oui sur un réseau social
vous avez posé avec dieudonné vous avez
parlé d'une société judéo maçonnique
donc moi ma question monsieur gouhier
elle est claire est ce que vous êtes
antisémites moi je suis pas venu pour
pour parler de ça je suis venu parler
sinon je vous parle de vous c'est
important dans le zou camarades ne suis
pas antisémite ne va pas très près alors
pourquoi l'avoir posée avec dieu donné
qu attends attends je vais c'est bon ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas le sujet de ce
soir c'est le sujet de ma question moi
je suis michèle cette question elle me
gêne absolument pas vous pouvez y
répondre mais moi je suis venu pour
parler de mon initiative ya du chapelet
et pas pour créer des polémiques il ne
serait pas une polémique je vous pose
dès lors pourquoi pourquoi ils vous
disent agir oui parce que yacine et dean
qui vient de parler de personnes qui
parlent qui sont passés et qui vous ont
traité de facho je pense que ça rejoint
saint thomas à ce que dit jc mais voilà
exact ccc à cc c'est pour ça qu'ils vous
pose est actuellement ces voix-là s'est
amené dans la rue on n'avait pas affiché
civitas on était juste de simples
catholique affiché seriez pas marqué
civitas sur nos têtes
il y avait non mais vous êtes dans le
calme et à ce mouvement vous appartenez
a soudainement tout à fait y est très
très très à droite d'extrême droite donc
mes questions je suis désolé elle
n'échappe pas totalement au coeur du
débat monsieur vous ne voulez pas
répondre mais je suis désolé que vous ne
répondiez pas parce que je trouve que
vous cacher des éléments importants pour
les téléspectateurs de votre
personnalité que vous êtes moi je ne
suis pas venu faire ce chapelet en tant
que que du fait que j'ai dû fait pu
faire une foot avec dû donner je suis
venu pour réparer un blasphème qui a été
commis envers les catholiques donc je
sais ce mon geste n'a pas été en vain
pour moi ça a été pour réparer tout le
tout ce qui a été fait envers les
catholiques oui mais dit géraldine je me
rappelle encore une fois que non mais le
délit de blasphème n'existe pas en
france
mais pour revenir à pour en revenir à
vos moi c'est une interrogation pourquoi
je peux comprendre monsieur que vous
ayez été heurté dans votre foi fois je
peux comprendre que ça vous est blessé
maintenant c'est chacun le vit ça vous
blesse aussi ce que ce que dit dieudonné
ou
comment ça vous blesse également ce que
dit dieudonné dans ses spectacles sur la
communauté juive
c'est pas forcément le sujet a eu envie
de parler de ce soir oui mais
il n'y a pas deux poids deux mesures oui
moi je suis de confession du ça m'a
choqué ce qu'a fait benjamin et je les
dis ici voilà j'ai je lui dit que
c'était une connerie je dis que ça
m'avait choqué vous vous êtes choqués
donc par ce qu'a fait benjamin vous
n'êtes pas choqué par ce que dit le
dieudonné dans ses spectacles john est
un humoriste que ce qu'il reste comme il
est moi ces îles et moi c'est pas moi de
geste qui fait si c'est bien ou pas il a
été condamné quand même quelqu'un qui
n'est pas feinte ça pose problème quand
même dieudonné mais pas balayer d'un
trait de plume à la main étaient venus
avec des animaux rice et vous aurez
derrière pas vous devrez donner
autant ah bon
pourquoi avoir manifesté votre votre
peine dans la rue parce que imaginons
que ça aurait été des maisons auraient
été des citoyens français de confession
musulmane
qu'est ce qu'on n'aurait pas entendu
dans dix ans les prières de rue les
prières de rue voilà vous n'êtes pas
dans l'église pour manifester votre
votre désir de dire que vous avez été
blessé pourquoi la le faire dans la rue
c'est une telle interrogation moi je
pense que l'on ne l'a pas fait d'un
important quel endroit nous l'avons fait
devant une église un lieu sacré pour les
catholiques et pourquoi dans la rue
parce que c'est important de montrer
publiquement que que catholiques ont été
outragé et qui sont choqués c'est
ça dérangeant voilà il voulait il
voulait faire un geste
il avait été choqué là dessus moi je ne
suis pas d'accord avec vous valérie là
ils aviseront et dont ils ont voulu ils
ont voulu marquer le coup et ils ont
trouvé ce moyen et je trouve que voilà
c'est normal parce qu'aujourd'hui on en
parle leasing ça fait peur mais coupat
et socialiser les catholiques pas né
catholique certain catholique oui merci
remportant 4 10 lorient catholiques
n'ont par exemple